[Music]
well it's finally come time that we have
to say goodbye to 2018 but what did the
year offer for us in our little corner
of anime
[Music]
2018 was a monster year for anime not
just in terms of the number of anime
coming out but in the quality of what's
available and the amount of exciting
announcements we have to look forward to
it's never been more exciting to be an
anime fan but anime still anime warts
and all so i'm here to celebrate the
best the worst and the weirdest anime
had to offer in this glorious year this
is anime in 2018
this year we're going to be doing things
a bit differently instead of going
through season by season there's just
been too much anime to go through so
instead i wanted to break things up into
categories for all the different things
that impacted me and the community this
year i can't guarantee that i'll cover
everything i can't even guarantee that
i'll cover every good show this year but
i will do my best as i definitely know
what i want to start with because there
was one relatively new company that
definitely made its mark on the industry
this year with an absolute bang
because they started it with an absolute
banger
[Applause]
[Music]
the show was actually devilman crybaby
yourself to sleep though that didn't
stop the community from absolutely
falling in love with this show as it
became everyone's obsession for the
start of the year we were in awe to the
experience that was the original
devilman dub the devilman dash took over
the naruto run even if it was just a
rehash of the scooby-doo sprint and of
course we were all bopping our heads to
one of the tracks of the year in a
phenomenon scientists have coined as an
absolute banger but of course netflix
didn't end there this year with many
more high-profile original and licenses
that would truly cement them as the
newest big player in this industry
agresco continued netflix's trend of
using funny harmless animal mascots to
hide a painfully relatable show sure to
start an existential crisis in his
workplace comedy drama the
personification of r slash mildly
infuriating as a show yeah
castlevania released a much positive
reception from the anime community
despite the fact that he wasn't made in
japan at all seriously jaeger and b the
beginning gave her some of the best
action direction this year had to offer
that not many people saw one of my
favorite small skirmishes is the
supersonic fight scene from b that
happens in the rain that they slow down
so the speed of the rain droplets
establish just how fast they are moving
[Music]
god it's so cool becky the grappler was
revived to show us the ideal male 4. in
an insane action show that was almost as
if someone looked at the likes of jojo's
special north star and dragon ball z and
goes wow what a bunch of [__] [__]
plus we had godzilla children of wales
high school girl ico incarnation and
more if there's one thing we can look
back at 2018 for it's for the start of
the anime streaming wars with anime
strike dead amazon prime doing almost
[__] all and crunchyroll and funimation
going through their relationship
troubles like i think we should get a
divorce like a real force netflix
certainly made their statement loud and
clear this year we're gonna be a big
part of this anime industry and we mean
[__] business now excuse me while i
go jam out to devilman utter a bit more
we're a long way from texas i learned
two important lessons this year one
isekai will never die ever you throw one
of them in a flaming dumpster and then
through the ashes three more majestic
burning bin liners will rise up to take
its place and two no matter how much i
complain about them i'll still end up
watching most of them anyway because to
me miseka is now that abusive partner i
keep coming back to even though i know
it's unhealthy and i realized this when
i finished death march to the parallel
world rhapsody which no is not the
newest my chemical romance album name
but the most by the books generic isekai
power fantasy show which i finished and
i still don't know why i did that but oh
boy did that start my downward spiral
into isekai this year master of ragnarok
and conception squared off to take the
crown for the worst isekai of the year
in one corner you have harem bait where
everyone is the main character's little
sister and in the other corner was the
pregnancy isekai with a guy getting
transported to another world to take
part in a ceremony called the love
ritual which in this world giggity
giggly is done to get girls pregnant
which sounds like an awful show idea and
was an awful show idea but you know what
at least we just have a simple story of
a guy who's finally found a world where
he can just get laid a bunch of times
i'm i'm happy for him the love ritual is
not a sexual act
[__] are you [__] kidding me how not
to summon the demon lord gave us
overlord high school dxd edition in the
show we've all seen before but somehow
enjoyed anyway i mean it even had a girl
called remnant for god's sakes though it
is nice to see an izakaya where rem is
actually best girl rather than the worst
that's great speaking of overlord the
fan favorite show returned with our most
beloved overpowered skeleton lord eins
being more ruthless than ever as viewers
slowly started to realize are we the
baddies the season gone at mixed
reception with lord eins's awesome world
takeover campaign being thwarted by bad
cg to rival berserk 2016. highlights
included the fearsome goblin army
battling a group of bowling pins and
whatever the [__] this climax was meant
to be let's have a round of applause for
this cg masterpiece
[Music]
however that time i got reincarnated as
a slime picked up any slack proving that
we all had one more place for a nisei
kai to worm its slimy way into all our
hearts i've already made a video about
this so i won't dwell on it but this was
the isekai that proved to me that i
could still fall in love with an isekai
show that went back to its roots but
that's it all right we're done nothing
isekai is ever going to surprise me
again because we've reached the limits
of everything this genre has to offer so
let's just all move on now all right
i am overpowered you think you're the
only protagonist transported to another
world
lord irons you've become part of a
bigger universe
you just don't know it yet
who the hell are you
called a coward director of trash
i'm here to talk to you about the
izakaya initiative
[Music]
no [__] way
foreign
[Music]
well there's anime there's bound to be
controversies let downs and of course
just straight up trash and as always
2018 did not fail to deliver rio's work
is never done ireland and my sister my
writer were just some of japan's
continuing efforts to buy trial and
error develop a weapon to surpass
aeromanga sensei in response the un
reminded japan that they will not
tolerate any research into the
development of future wmds weapons of
mass degeneracy the edge award this year
was a clear toss-up between mahou shojo
sights and killing bites the first
featuring more sharp edges included than
a doki doki date with yuri and the other
being the furry beat down galore giving
us our favorite kind of boner the y
boner and then we have the yuri anime
citrus giving us our other favorite kind
of boner the cry boner the reiku had
that one guy
in every hentai you've ever seen
you know the one fist of the blue sky
showed us some next level [__] while
persona personified the animation forgot
the second part of his own name giving
us the blandest video game adaptation
since every video game adaptation ever i
guess you could say fans never saw that
happening
you didn't say the thing i'll go the
[__] to sleep and of course we have the
story of the two shows that kicked up
the biggest storm this year darling in
the franxx and goblin slayer both shows
had some pretty decent hype going into
them i mean one was a collaboration
between a1 pictures and the much-loved
studio trigger and the other had a
pretty loyal following from his source
material so you know what it looks
promising frank's bringing back the good
old 2d mecha goodness we've all missed
with some premium trigger hype along
with what's this butt control oh trigger
back at it again with the peak of human
engineering and look it's a dungeons and
dragons inspired fantasy world with a
man named goblin slayer who slays
goblins on a show called goblin slayer
not sure what this anime could be about
but what's the worst that could happen
alright so frank's turning out to be a
pretty introspective character drama
which i wasn't expecting but damn i am
on board this is the cutest thing ever
zero two is clearly best girl of the
season we even got some girl with a rem
haircut going against zero two i can see
where this is going more like rem hair
cuck am i right wait a minute what are
you doing with this no no no i don't i
don't like where this is going friends
what is it what is she oh god why why
would you let her do that no no
what would you do with that tomorrow
goblin slayer you can save me right but
wait wait wait no no what is this mess
oh god look at the [__] internet
goblins goblins goblins why are there so
many goblins everywhere why is alex
jones talking about goblins what's the
[__] sake sword out of line why are
you getting involved too this is like
your third [__] time where the [__]
are you frank where the [__] is piloting
this vehicle right now who's in charge
of the frank's ride
why are there aliens why are we in space
why is zero two a giant [__] space
waifu what the [__] is going on
[Music]
this year we got no shortage of
absolutely beautiful shows and stories
anime that would suck you into their
world and characters connect with you on
a level not many other things could and
occasionally even take your breath away
shows like after the rain flavors of
youth continuing anime's declaration of
war against real-life food some of the
best background work all year was done
by irizuku with the world of colours and
by god was it absolutely stunning bloom
into you portrayed one of the most
relatable down-to-earth romantic
relationships i've seen in anime that
explores our perception of what love is
as teenagers what we expect it to be and
what we actually experience when we find
our first relationship and i think it
says a lot about how well they handled
this given that the romance i related to
the most this year happen to be one
between two anime girls however despite
all these shows being great i think it's
pretty amazing we got blessed with three
of the most beautiful shows of the year
within the single span of winter despite
my initial reservations there was
something quite magical about violet
evergarden in this age of instant
communication it can be easy to forget
what the charm of a simple letter was
but when you are forced to limit your
communication to a single a4 piece of
paper it makes the words you choose that
much more important the series through
its various stories made me realize just
how much i took for granted the art of
expressing your emotions and i had my
favorite singular standalone episode of
the year episode 10 is a goddamn
masterpiece that you don't even need to
watch the rest of the series to enjoy
it's just unfortunate that my complete
disinterest in miss fullmetal saber
herself as a character never left and
the series was much more appealing to me
when violet was just a vehicle to tell
other people's stories i'm just kidding
violet you can't be anything like saber
cause she's already saber maybe i'll be
saber i'm already saber actually i'm
already saber um no i'm already safe no
you're all wrong i'm the original saber
then we have finding the right group of
friends to share some remarkable
experience with and doing that thing
you've told yourself you were gonna do
the simple journey of four girls finding
their way to antarctica was breathtaking
it was joyous it was silly it was
bittersweet it was heartbreaking and by
god was it inspiring who knew that this
serendipitous meeting between a group of
girls going on this awe-inspiring
odyssey could ignite some fire in me to
want to achieve something incredible
cute girls doing cute things
nah i prefer cute girls doing amazing
things
pick up his new identity i am sad
scientist it's so gloom
son of a [__] turkey ghoul
[Music]
confused anime and manga fans alike but
at least it gave the viewers exactly
what they were waiting for as
celebrations could be felt around the
anime community as an entire fandom
excitedly cheered on one man epically
failing no nuts november and finally
attack on titan season 3 continued the
show's ever evolving plot developments
in a new season that had less to do with
attacking titans and was more like a
high-stakes political drama following an
internal power struggle i would say
became like the game of thrones of anime
but i wouldn't because now that's become
a far overused comparison that has lost
all meaning from everyone and their mum
using it to describe every show and i
think a much more unique way to describe
it is that it's basically just the dark
souls of anime by far the highlight of
this new season was the discovery of new
best girl historia being the sleeper hit
this entire time who finally skyrocketed
past all other contestants who takes a
clear lead in the best girl race
unfortunately due to scheduling issues
the hype of season 3 would be cut short
to actually be continued next year which
was so sad alexa place a saga yo
here's a sample of despacito remix alexa
no
finally in the rest of the year we also
had a mix of surprising hype and just
downright weird stuff to round off 2018
in anime in the sports corner run with
the win was probably my pick for most
underrated sports anime of this year
hanebado had some of the best sports
direction and animation even if it took
itself way too [__] seriously and
really should have come with some kind
of splash warning with the enormous
amount of sweat that was shed every
match however this was the year megalo
box put the box back into boxing in a
hype as [__] reimagining of a classic
boxing manga with a soundtrack that was
hashtag an absolute banger bananafish
gave us a stylish crime gangster
thriller that hit all the right notes
while showcasing mapper's newfound power
after yuri and ice to be able to control
the moistness of all yowie fan girls at
will osmosis jones got its anime
adaptation and cells at work providing a
cute educational show about the human
body we got to learn about all our
favorite cells see that's red blood
cells you got white blood cells you got
platelets you got uh sperm cells cancer
cells oh that's just straight up stage
four leukemia here's my brain cells when
it's four am and i have a seven o'clock
meeting oh and there they are again when
i'm trying to do anything productive
ever
i don't want to make out a fresh look of
paint this year firstly there were
theater lesbians trying to kill each
other on stage to the sound of j-pop in
review starlight we got horse idols and
uma musume giving us some nico nico
oh god i'm so sorry zombieland saga was
the first idol show i enjoyed immensely
it was a great show but was just let
down by god awful cg performances that
would have made the climaxes hit so much
more harder i mean i wasn't exactly a
fan of lovelive's use of cg but even
that looks ten times better than what we
saw here god maybe i should just watch
love live instead wait what the [__] did
i just say we got a [__] post cleverly
disguised as an anime series in pop team
epic the faithful were rewarded as jojo
fans finally got to see the dance they
were all waiting for in yet another jojo
reference that makes absolutely no sense
out of context
and probably in context sss sss grid man
brought the hype back to trigger shows
after franks had killed it danced on his
grave and shot it up into space
providing some of the hypest action
scenes along with the most unique and
atmospheric direction in any anime of
that no one really cared about because
lord have mercy on my soul we've found a
new religion and it was rika tatarana's
thighs kinamatsuri truly blindsided me
by providing one of the most wholesome
anime of the entire year despite being
hyped up as comedy of the season yes
we're going to visit from the fields
train experiencing a yakuza getting to
play a father figure to a collection of
some absolutely adorable little girls
giving us some good old daughter porn
wait no that's that camera that's that's
not what i meant the best girl debate
was instead replaced with best daughter
which of course was anzu because she's
the most precious thing in this entire
world versus hina who in a nutshell is
an absolute piece of [__] but god i love
her and finally rascal does not dream of
bunny girl senpai prove that click
baiting doesn't just work for youtube
videos by baiting an audience with the
promise of plot only to have viewers
stay for
plot
with some of the best girls and some of
the best written dialogue all year that
was basically the equivalent of playing
through a visual novel picking every
troll dialogue option along the way and
somehow ending up with the harem ending
the series had one of the catchiest ops
all season had viewers singing along to
the opening line of every episode many
have pointed out that the lyrics to the
song sound like this but i'm not so sure
let's see if that's true if every word
is pronounced properly
[Music]
oh yeah that's that's definitely it and
that was anime in 2018 it's been a year
of hype year of tears year of great
girls year of controversy year of
incredibly inspirational [__] year of
absolute [__] bangers and most of all
it's been a great [__] year of anime
i hope you've had a happy new year thank
you for sticking with me through this
year and let's get ready for 2019
happy 2019 guys hope you had a great
2018 and an awesome new year
it's uh been a journey thanks to all of
you who stuck with me through this year
thank you to everyone who supports me on
patreon that allows me to do passion
projects like this video that i know are
going to get you know demonetized or
copyright claims but i don't want to
sacrifice the vision that i have and i
can do it thanks to the support you guys
give i hope you all have enjoyed what
i've been making the past year and i
hope you continue to stick with me as i
just want to make good [__] that i enjoy
and i hopefully you enjoy too anyway i
have not had any holiday in the past
month thanks to this video so i'm gonna
take a much needed rest i hope you all
have a great year and i will see you
next time